well we've told you repeatedly over the
last couple of weeks about how the FAA
which is in charge of your safety when
you travel by air has altered its merit
based hiring testing for air traffic
controllers adding a bogus biographical
questionnaire to the process the new
test existence is bad enough they are
seeking out the unqualified
intentionally but even more worrisome
than that is the fact that the FAA
apparently didn't care if people cheated
on their already watered-down test in
2016 Department of Transportation found
that the National black coalition of
Federal Aviation employees had given its
members guidance on how to answer the
biographical questionnaire so they could
pass it in other words the group helped
them cheat by giving them the correct
answers ahead of time cheating on a
federal hiring test is a crime and it
ought to be and yet despite that nobody
was ever charged in fact one union
member connected to the cheating appears
to be still employed by the FAA Michael
Pearson is a former air-traffic
controller he's an attorney and he's
involved in litigation surrounding the
FAA hiring practices he joins us tonight
Michael Pearson thanks a lot for coming
on first this is such a strong
allegation that I want to get to how you
know this to be absolutely true
well it I've been involved in this since
it actually began when I first heard
about it with the purging of the list of
folks so we're watching your show there
remember that you had thousands of
people on the list that were qualified
including military with military
experience and aviation experience that
all of a sudden was purged in the AI
phase words and then folks were forced
to go through this biographical
questionnaire which was designed by an
outside vendor and so for the last
several years including the litigation
that my firm along with Mountain States
legal foundation brought we've been able
to dig up information through the
Freedom of Information Act process as
well as the litigation process so not
only do we have internal people tell us
this was going on that they were afraid
that if they would come forward the FAA
would penalize them the d-o-t penalize
them in fairly high levels of the
government but now we have actual
documentary evidence that substantiates
our worst fears
so the Union helped people cheat on the
test again just to put this in context
to become air traffic controllers and
control commercial aviation millions use
it every year people could die as a
result of this and yet no one was ever
charged for that why well it wasn't the
Union wasn't air traffic across it was a
MBC FA it's a employee group the
national black coalition of federal
aviation employees certainly did that
and it was a process started from early
to 2012 2013 there was a group within
that organization who determined that
the makeup of the workforce was too
white they wanted to get a more diverse
workforce they started lobbying through
the political process which is certainly
allowed to however they then crafted
this BQ exam which not manat a screening
test it actually turned out that the
scoring rubric that actually penalized
people with aviation experience pilots
air traffic controllers and then to make
it worse they had folks stand in line
for this test that they someone in the
MVC FAA that apparently gotten the
answers to and coached other people how
to pass the test so not only were our
best and brightest as the FAA says
actually purged off the list they then
were forced through a screening process
that discriminated against them
intentionally on the scoring of the test
so most if not the great great majority
of them failed that exam while people
were given the answers and how to pass
the test even more important recent
documents show that when this individual
was interviewed he'd gave in a written
statement saying that he didn't do that
then he went into a verbal interview
with a do T OIG criminal investigator
said he didn't do it he had his attorney
with him
incredibly the do T OIG investigator
allowed him to see witness statements
contradicting that and then allowed him
to go out of the room with his attorney
come back in and change his story that's
it's not done anybody in law enforcement
or the law from the legal side from an
attorney side or a criminal
investigation side knows that that's
beyond unusual
that's crafting an investigation to meet
a predetermined outcome I ain't nothing
went wrong this investigation
started due to people like Frank
LoBiondo Randy wholegrain members of
Congress on both sides of the aisle that
we're concerned about this process and
the d-o-t OIG investigators final result
are basically his is suggestion or his
recommendation was that this not be
forwarded to the Department of Justice
for a criminal investigation this thing
started at the high level the d-o-t it's
a cover-up at the very highest level and
you have all people people involve from
both the d-o-t and FA and ironically
enough the architects the implementers
and the facilitators are still employed
at high levels within the FAA they
should I never say this but these are
people who should be in prison because
they're imperiling public safety on a
mass scale at the very least Tucker what
should happen is the deal Jay along with
the FBI should investigate what really
went on and what really occurred and
then the process and due process of law
should be followed and the folks in the
FA at the highest management levels that
designed this the architects
implementers and certainly the
facilitators should be brought to
justice as you say it's most civilly and
criminally illegal to do what happened
here
the air traffic control system in a
country you're basically third world at
that point I mean if you can't maintain
high standards of air traffic control
then it's over Michael Carson thank you
for that you're very welcome Tucker